bei lichte betrachtet und von nahem
gesehen hängt wie wir die aktualität und
die welt sehen immer auch davon ab bogen
und durch wessen kameras wir diese welt
sehen es ist möglich dass ein und
derselbe fakt zum beispiel der kampf
gegen terroristen um die
meinungsfreiheit schon in der türkei
erst recht aber in china ganz anders
gesehen wird oder bringt guter
journalismus überall die gleiche
wahrheit ans licht
und genau darüber zu reden habe ich eine
türkische und eine chinesische star news
moderatorin die ich ende januar am wef
kennengelernt habe
ins studio geladen wir haben uns unter
news vermittlung nicht abgesprochen und
so bin ich nun selbst gespannt wie sehr
die brille der herkunft die wir tragen
das bild beeinflusst dass wir sehen
seien sie ganz herzlich willkommen hier
in der winterlichen schweiz
trinken sie schon als kind davon eine
berühmte moderatorin in ihrem riesigen
land zu werden
als ich klein war das fernsehen für
china ganz neu
ich erinnere mich dass der ganze hof
platz voller leute war gut zwei dutzend
die sich bei unseren nachbarn in einem
engen raum zusammen drängten weil diese
als einzige einen fernseher besaßen
einen so kleinen vitali hatten damals
fernsehen
wir hatten diesen anziehungspunkt gleich
gegenüber und wir alle klebten förmlich
am fernseher das liegt erst 30 jahre
zurück aber nun 30 jahre später hat
china sich verändert und unsere
ansprüche haben sich auch verändern aber
haben sie schon als kleines mädchen
gewünscht auf diesem bildschirm zu sein
nie hätte ich gesagt so etwas zu denken
das kam erst später als die reformen
kamen
da war ich an der universität da wollte
ich dj wären und ich wurde dj drei
monate mit rock'n roll
doch dann dachte ich die jungs sind
vermutlich interessanter weil sie aus
der ganzen welt kommen und ich die
verschiedensten leute kennenlernen und
sehen sie da bin ich und setzte ihnen
gegenüber stefan und spreche zu einem
europäischen publikum ist uns aber was
ordnen ihren traum als kleines mädchen
ich hatte keine große vorstellung als
ich im kindergarten war wollte ich
lehrerin werden und als ich größer wurde
hatte ich verschiedene träume hatten sie
ein vorbild
ich habe eines es ist kein polit star
auch kein meinungsmacher bei den medien
sondern meine großmutter wie das denn
vor zwei jahren starb sie 100 jahre alt
sie war eine sehr traditionelle
chinesische frau mit gebundenen füßen
die kein einziges schriftzeichen kannte
aber auch schon sie aus einem kleinen
abgelegenen man syrischen dorf stammte
hatte sie offenbar aus dem nichts den
ehrgeiz dass ihre zwei töchter zur
schule gehen sollten nicht mehr zur
schule sondern auch zur universität
denn sie begriff schon damals dass
frauen unabhängig sein und selbstständig
arbeiten sollen dasselbe tag meine
mutter und so wurde es mir möglich in
der großstadt zu leben und wie viele
andere junge chinesinnen eine ausbildung
zu bekommen und berufliche ambitionen zu
haben
ausgezeichnet und sie so nah wie delhi
wie sind sie zu einem der berühmten
gesichter ihres landes geworden der
türkei als ich jung war schaute ich fern
und ich wusste schon mit 13 14 jahren
dass ich journalistin und moderatorin
werden wollte
das habe ich damals als ganz junges
mädchen beschlossen als türkin gehört
man irgendwie in eine kategorie für
ich war mir als heranwachsende meiner
türkischen identität als moderne junge
türkische frau sehr bewusst aber auch
meine muslimischen identität
die türken haben glaube ich eine
besondere stellung in der islamischen
welt
wir sind offener gegenüber veränderungen
sind fortschrittlicher als ich aufwuchs
wollte ich mich selbst bestätigen wollte
mein land vertreten in der welt wollte
dies tun als journalistin in den medien
ich wollte ein beispiel sein für eine
fortschrittliche muslimische frauen ich
glaube ich war 14 da sagte ich mama papa
ich werde journalistin und ich wollte
zum studium nach amerika gehen und die
eltern sagten sie haben mich sehr
unterstützt
was machen ihre haltung mein vater ist
geschäftsmann meine mutter hat einen
universitätsabschluss sie sind beide
sehr gebildet aber kein journalist in
der familie nicht wirklich ich erklärte
ihm einen plan
ich gehe nach hobart und studierte
politikwissenschaft dann komme ich
zurück und tue das und das ich kann
ihnen sagen dass ich gott dankbar bin
für die möglichkeit meine träume zu
leben denn einen traum haben ist das
eine aber ich war auch in der lage
meinen traum zu verwirklichen
ich habe hart dafür gearbeitet aber
dennoch ist es nicht einfach zu haben
ich denke ja glück ist eine andere
bezeichnung für gottes wille
also ich habe hart gearbeitet und gott
hat mir geholfen
ich war sechs jahre in den staaten und
nachdem ich mein studium abgeschlossen
hatte
ich habe meinen master in hart gemacht
begann ich gleich nach meiner rückkehr
zu arbeiten
ich war die jüngste moderatoren an einem
türkischen fernsehen
als ich bei cnn türk begann wie haben
sie das geschafft gingen sie einfach
vorbei und sagen da bin ich ich bin gut
ihr müsst
ich war bereits als studentin bekannt
man lud mich ein als ich in harvard
studierte sie luden mich als gast ins
fernsehstudio zu politischen themen
so hatte ich bereits während des
studiums eine anhängerschaft ich hatte
wirklich glück als ich zurückkam erhielt
ich angebote
ich war 25 als ich die abendnachrichten
moderierte bei channel die und dann cnn
türk
ich war also eine der jüngsten
moderatorinnen und war über zehn jahre
beim türkischen fernsehsendern
verglichen mit sonar verlief mein weg im
zickzack er gleich dem weg den china
zurückgelegt hat dazu fällt mir ein
berühmter ausspruch von dank shopping
ein dem wegbereiter der chinesischen
reformen dass wir beim durchschreiten
des flusses die steine fühlen müssen
vielleicht ohne schon zu wissen wohin
wir gelangen werden
wir müssen auf das licht am ende des
tunnels schauen
ich hatte so eine dreisprung karriere
dort vorhin erzählte begann ich als dj
dann arbeitete ich im
nachrichtenprogramm bei einem
radiosender
damals war radio wie sie vielleicht
wissen nicht gerade das höchste was man
machen konnte
doch schließlich schaffte ich den sprung
nach washington wo ich während der
kriege im irak und afghanistan als
korrespondentin arbeitete und mich mit
meinen internationalen kollegen
austauschen konnte ich erinnere mich
ganz am anfang da saß ich im briefing
room des state department und wusste gar
nicht was off the record heißt das
wussten sie nicht das wusste ich nicht
denn journalismus ist in china immer
noch etwas ganz neues kann man sander
uni studieren
ja es gibt an der universität
vorlesungen über journalismus
es ist alles noch im anfangsstadium das
hat natürlich zwei seiten
zum einen wird man nicht eingeengt durch
regeln und leitlinien auf der anderen
seite muss man sich an etwas halten um
vorwärts zu kommen
es ist wirklich wie schwimmen und die
steine fühlen beim überqueren des
flusses das ist ein wunderbares gefühl
ich finde für wii und für mich weil es
schwieriger sie ist chinesin und ich
türkin und ich bin überzeugt dass es für
unsere westlichen kollegen vielleicht
nicht leichter ist aber wir müssen gegen
kulturelle barrieren und vorurteile
ankämpfen
ich wollte gerade sie beide fragen nur
bis für sie als frauen ein vor oder ein
nachteil war
es ist kein vorteil
stellen sie sich vor bestimmt wird bei
mir zustimmen erstens du bist türkin
zwei musst du bist muslimen im westen in
europa gibt es viele vorurteile über
diese eigenschaften
wenn man wie wir aus einem solchen land
kommt muss man besonders hart arbeiten
um sich zu beweisen
man muss zum beispiel in den usa zur
schule gehen und dort fragte man was
will das türkische mädchen hier
amerika war im vergleich zu europa etwas
offener
aber man muss kämpfen auch für die
muslimische identität
schnell heißt es ach du bist aus der
türkei aber dann bist du wohl
muslimischer ist immer diese
überraschung
ich finde der westen braucht etwas
nachhilfe unterricht
wir beide haben zwar das glück dass wir
es geschafft haben aber unsere
kolleginnen in europa oder in amerika
haben es doch etwas leichter
darum kommen wir wohl mit diesem gefühl
der verpflichtung ein gutes vorbild zu
sein
wir stehen mehr unter druck den wir
vertreten unser land und unsere
identität
sagen für mich sind freilich die
schwierigkeiten die sie erwähnen bei
allen herausforderungen
auch ein selbst erziehungsprozess der
das verständnis für viele journalisten
fördern kann
ich spreche von den erfahrungen des
bürgerjournalismus wenn ich unterbrechen
darf
die frage ist doch das will ich noch
sagen es ist auch wichtig zu wissen dass
wir in china dramatische veränderungen
erleben jeden tag gibt es zahllose
nachrichten weil sich dieses land so
schnell wandelt das ist eine sehr
glückliche sache für eine journalistin
bin ich damals vor zehn jahren
berichtete ich in washington über die
kriege im irak und afghanistan
nachdem der sogenannte physische krieg
vorbei war brach in china die source
pandemie aus und da dachte ich warum
sitze ich als chinesische journalistin
immer noch hier im state department
briefing room warum gehe ich nicht
einfach zurück und berichte über die
wichtigste geschichte der welt die in
meinem land stattfindet darum ging ich
zurück und es zeigte sich dass eine
solche ausland erfahrung hilft
herauszufinden wer wir selbst sind und
dass wir mehr verständnis entwickeln für
unsere eigene und für fremde kulturen
nur nebenbei ich stelle fest dass es
viel schwieriger ist eine
nachrichtenmoderatorin wie sie zu
unterbrechen weil wir über dieselben
techniken und die gleiche ausbildung
verfügen ich muss aufpassen und sie
respektieren auch die damen ja ich hoffe
nicht gegen die chinesische höflichkeit
zu verstoßen
ich wollte sie fragen in ihrem land in
china ist das lächerlich zu fragen ob es
einen unterschied macht ein mann oder
eine frau zu sein
in china legte der vorsitzende mao eine
große gestalt der modernen geschichte zu
sagen die frauen tragen die hälfte des
himmels
natürlich war das ein politischer slogan
und
frauen müssen sich beweisen die
generation meiner mutter musste äußerst
hart arbeiten um das zu erreichen was
die frauen heute sind meine generation
wurde in eine übergangszeit
hineingeboren von der zeit der reinen
politisch ideologischen zeit in eine
pragmatischere weltoffene zeit in dieser
übergangszeit haben wir frauen um unsere
identität zu finden eine phase
durchlaufen an der es wichtig war einen
eigenen standpunkt einzunehmen und sich
nicht auf die errungenschaften unserer
mütter abzustützen
doch wenn man die möglichkeit hat zu
wählen entscheiden sich manche frauen
keine liberale und unabhängige frau
sondern etwas anderes zu werden etwas
das als traditionellen altmodisch
angesehen wird aber die leute haben die
wahl
andererseits habe ich als berufstätige
frau in china viele kolleginnen die sich
selbst beweisen wollen das sie
gleichzeitig frau und beruflich
erfolgreich sein können
tatsächlich ist die sendung die ich in
china moderiere eine diskussionssendung
zur globalen themen
es ist weltweit immer noch selten dass
frauen sendungen zur hand news
moderieren die sendung ist eine tägliche
sendung 45 minuten jeden tag live mit
globalen themen was einem viertel
ich habe jeden tag die herausforderung
des tages thema zu wählen
denn in china ist viel los und gerade
jetzt auch auf der ganzen welt
chinesische und internationale themen
und internationale themen zum glück
stehen heute viele dieser themen
miteinander in verbindung und um zu
ihnen zu nach sie haben für mtv türkei
gearbeitet das war ja vor gut 20 jahren
die nachrichtensender welches war ihre
sendung ich bin eine primetime
moderatorin in der türkei meine sendung
hieß panorama das konzept ist folgendes
ich lud prominente internationale
persönlichkeiten ein
es war eine wöchentliche sendung und ich
heißt viel ich interviewte
persönlichkeiten wie königin rania von
jordanien tom friedman den führenden
kolumnisten der new york times
ich befragte zakaria den moderator
basieren und auch den begründer des wef
klaus schwab den ich neulich in china
interviewte ich heiße dafür nach tieren
sich hat es sehr gut meine sendung
sollte ein fenster zur welt öffnen darum
legte ich das schwergewicht auf
persönlichkeiten außerhalb der türkei
auf prominente die etwas geleistet haben
aber für ein türkisches zielpublikum
typischen neue perspektiven zu eröffnen
natürlich die türkische gesellschaft ist
mit der welt sehr verbunden
sie liebt an den verbindungswegen
zwischen ost und west
wir sind in istanbul stationiert die
halbe stadt liegt in asien die andere
hälfte in europa es gibt also viel zu
reisen aber als teil meines berufes als
moderatorin muss sich auch konferenzen
wie hier das heft besuchen in davos bin
ich jetzt zum sechsten mal
ich moderiere konferenzen in davos ich
moderierte aber auch in jordanien am
nahost-gipfel des weltwirtschaftsforums
dann war ich in dubai und in tianjin in
china
wir reisen zu diesen plattformen
ich war auch in sankt petersburg wo
putin die russischen konferenzen
organisiert auch da habe ich moderiert
ich muss also nicht nur meine sendung
moderieren und sondern auch mein land
vertreten an verschiedenen foren sei es
die clinton global initiative in new
york oder etwas das
malaysia stattfindet dafür muss man eine
weltgewandte person sein mit unserer
arbeit besteht nicht nur aus
journalismus dieses jahr freue ich mich
besonders dass mich das
weltwirtschaftsforum als young global
leader nominiert hat das resultat wird
im märz bekanntgegeben
wenn ich gewählt werde könnte ich noch
zusätzliche verantwortung übernehmen das
sind wichtige foren für uns um mit
unseren kollegen ideen auszutauschen
wenn sie so als internationale
journalistin herumreisen
glauben sie dass sie als moderne
muslimin eine andere perspektive
vermitteln als jemand der aus einer
anderen religion oder kultur kommt
bestimmt
diese konferenzen bieten uns die
gelegenheit verschiedene leute zu
treffen und auch unsere religion zu
vertreten
ich will ihnen eine interessante episode
erzählen es war 2008 ich besuchte die
konferenz des weltzeitungsverbandes
damals waren bereits die
mohammed-karikaturen in dänischen
zeitungen erschienen die
zeitungen ja und in meinem buch um saß
auch der damalige chefredaktor von
charlie hebdo philipp wahl sowie einige
leute von dänischen zeitungen
wir hatten angeregte diskussionen
als muslimische türken bemerkte ich dass
solche zeichnungen für muslime
beleidigend seien und wohl auch für
juden muslime und juden sind vielleicht
etwas empfindlicher als die christen in
bezug auf ihre propheten und wir haben
eben diese tradition dass man den
propheten nicht darstellt
sagten sie ihm dass man so etwas nicht
veröffentlichen sollte nein sie wollten
einfach nur ich glaube an die
meinungsäusserungsfreiheit ich fragte
nur philipp wenn sie solche cartoons
veröffentlichen sollten sie wissen dass
sie den spielraum der gemäßigten muslime
einengen und den radikalen in der
islamischen welt in die hände spielen
denn die radikalen und extremisten
kommen dann und sagen schaut was der
westen mit diesen karikaturen gemacht
hat sie beleidigen uns was sagte der
chefredaktor dazu ich wollte noch sagen
die gemäßigten muslime werden in die
enge getrieben
sie wissen nicht was sie sagen sollen er
hat ganz höflich geantwortet und wir
hatten ein produktives gespräch
was ich aber noch sagen möchte ich
verurteile die attentate denn als wahre
muslim sollte man wie folgt handeln ist
man beleidigt oder hält etwas für
blasphemie dann spreche man höflich und
versuche der anderen person die
sensibilitäten der religion zu erklären
der mann angehört der koran sagt wenn du
mit einer beleidigung oder blasphemie
gegen deine religion konfrontiert bist
dann geh weg verlasse den ort er sagt
nicht greift zu den waffen und töte ich
war tief erschüttert und verurteile
entschieden solche attacken und ich
glaube die schweizer bevölkerung sollte
wissen dass die meisten muslime der
gleichen überzeugung sind wie ich wir
sind gegen terrorismus
das herz schmerzt uns wenn wir solche
leute sehen das sind keine muslime die
so etwas tun der eine polizist der stab
war muslim und sein bruder sagte mein
bruder war ein muslim und wurde getötet
von männern die behaupten muslime zu
sein
ich wollte das nur geklärt habe klar
wenn wir davon sprechen was ein
journalist sagen kann und was nicht
unterschiedliche kulturen antworten er
unterschiedlich auf die frage wie weit
man gehen kann wie freimann ist sie
beschreiben den prozess der öffnung
was würden sie sagen ihre grenzen seien
dieselben wie unsere grenzen ich sehe so
manches stereotyp in ihren fragen stefan
das muss ich ganz offen gestehen zuerst
ihre frage ob frauen in unserem beruf
mehr schwierigkeiten haben als männer
zweitens ob wir in china mehr
schwierigkeiten haben themen zu
behandeln als der rest der welt wollen
sie von mir keinen kommentar zur
scharnier der geschichte
doch wir hatten nämlich in meiner
sendung in china eine ganze woche lang
an vier von fünf tagen diskussionen
darüber etwas was mir wichtig ist ist
die welt nicht zu sehen als du oder ich
sondern die welt als ganzes zu sehen
viele menschen betrachten die
globalisierung als etwas abstraktes aber
das ist sie nicht
diese vorstellung versuche ich in meine
sendung einzubauen
sie heißt world inside täglich 45
minuten live auf mtv news der
internationalen abteilung des
staatlichen chinesischen fernsehen
einer meiner grundsätze ist die bühne
nicht zu beherrschen nicht dem publikum
zu sagen was ich denke ich bin ja nur
die gastgeberin der sendung ich bin die
vermittlerin
ich bilde einen ruhenden pol um den
herum die verschiedenen ins thema
involvierten studiogäste ihre ansichten
austauschen
meine aufgabe ist sie zu ermuntern und
sie reden zu lassen über ihre eigene
sicht der dinge und nicht über die meine
china befindet sich in einem sehr
interessanten stadium
und wenn sie stefan die gelegenheit
haben nach china zu reisen
nicht nur für eine woche sondern für ein
paar jahre werden sie verstehen dass
sich die psyche der chinesen verändert
zum beispiel bis letztes jahr moderierte
ich eine sendung über zehn jahre lang
deren konzept bestand aus einem gespräch
im pekinger studio mit gästen vor allem
aus
china und die absicht war die stimme
chinas in die welt hinauszutragen doch
jetzt sind wir bereits eine stufe weiter
mit dem aufstieg chinas und seiner
wachsenden wirtschaftlichen stärke und
mit dem interesse der menschen an china
nur stellt sich die frage ob wir offen
genug sind eine stufe zu erreichen auf
der alle sprechen können ist nicht nur
chinesin nach dem motto macht die ohren
auf und hört unsere stimme viel mehr
schaffen wir eine plattform wo sie ihre
meinung sagen und ich die meine und
manchmal braucht es nicht einmal eine
chinesische stimme
es sei denn es ist ein thema das mit
china zu tun hat zb das thema islam
wir haben eine riesige muslimische
bevölkerungsgruppe in china eine unsere
autonomen regionen heißt ungarisches
shenyang
dort ist die mehrheit der bevölkerung
muslimisch viele geschichten rund um die
welt haben einen bezug zu meiner heimat
darum finde ich es wichtig verschiedene
stimmen zu hören und nicht china centris
sondern vielmehr welt centris zu sein
diese botschaft ist mir sehr wichtig
journalisten und moderatoren wie wir
müssen sich selbst disziplinieren
aber ich sehe ja sie diskutieren in
dieser sendung mit meiner kollegin aus
der türkei und mit mir aus china beide
aus kulturen die sehr verschieden sind
von der ihren
ich kann ihnen zu dieser wunderbaren
ideen nur gratulieren nun aber zum thema
charlie hebdo wir machten dazu vier
sendungen in fünf tagen wir erfuhren und
erfahren noch immer viel anteilnahme aus
dem chinesischen publikum an dem was in
paris geschah ist das auf große
aufmerksamkeit
absolut die menschen in china wie
übrigens auch in der türkei sind äußerst
interessiert am weltgeschehen
solchen tat welche gegen das fundament
der menschlichkeit verstößt nämlich
niemandem ein leid zuzufügen der kein
krimineller ist
wir haben enorm viel an teilgenommen
aber ich muss sagen dass es verschiedene
stufen von anteilnahme gibt im ersten
moment sind die menschen einfach
entsetzt über diese grauenvolle tat der
terroristen
die menschen kleben an den bildschirmen
und verfolgen jeden schritt obwohl es so
weit weg ist
selbst wenn es so weit weg ist wie ich
vorhin sagte das geht auch uns etwas an
denn wir haben in unserem land eine
riesige muslimische bevölkerung und darf
ich auch unsere zuschauer in der schweiz
und auch in europa informieren
das erst vor einem jahr im märz 2014 in
meinem land in der südwestlichen provinz
yunnan auf dem bahnhof der
provinzhauptstadt wo stets viele leute
zusammenkommen
29 menschen getötet wurden und 140
schwer verletzt als ergebnis einer
terrorattacke von einigen extremisten
diese geschichte wurde in china und auch
im ausland breit kommuniziert
aber wir finden sie verschiedene
herangehensweisen an diese geschichte
noch heute setzen gewisse sender in
ihrer beschreibung den terrorakt in
anführungszeichen
doch für viele chinesen ist das
definitiv ein terrorakt
was ich damit sagen will und auch in
meiner sendung fragte ist ob es
verschiedene allen gibt an denen wir
unsere anteilnahme für die opfer messen
welche unschuldige zivilpersonen sind
keine frage die ganze welt sagt diese
leute sind kriminelle und diese sache
hat absolut nichts mit religion zu tun
in anderen konflikten aber ist für den
einen ein terrorist was für den anderen
ein freiheitskämpfer ist was denken sie
über diese frage wie formulieren sie
wenn sie über den nahostkonflikt
sprechen der sehr wichtig ist für einen
sender wie den ihren
ich muss zugeben für 99 prozent der
islamischen welt sind diese leute keine
freiheitskämpfer es gibt eine klare
trennung und das konnten sie sehen
sie spreche noch immer von den
terroristen
ja sie haben eine politische agenda
keine religiöse sondern eine politische
agenda
sie versuchen ereignisse zu schaffen in
diesem fall den angriff auf charlie
hebdo welche den größtmöglichen
aufschrei provozieren ob sie durch die
karikaturen beleidigt waren oder nicht
spielt keine rolle
es ist ein terrorakt aus einer
politischen motivation heraus wenn wir
in der islamischen welt diese tat
analysieren finden wir dass auch der
westen aufpassen und nicht noch öl ins
feuer gießen sollte
wir sind gegen jede art von terrorismus
jede anwendung von gewalt und wir
verurteilen diesen terrorismus aber
bringen sie diese bande von verbrechern
nicht mit dem rest der islamischen welt
in verbindung
natürlich ich finde es wichtig für die
schweiz für frankreich wo über fünf
millionen muslime leben für ganz europa
dass sie dies nicht der muslimischen
bevölkerung an lassen und es sie fühlen
lassen
in vielen muslimen die in europa leben
macht diese sache zu schaffen
sie fürchten sich vor diskriminierung
europa kann es bestimmt besser
europa hat eine großartige
zivilgesellschaft und das ist auch ein
test für europa macht ihr die ganze
muslimische bevölkerung dafür
verantwortlich oder geht es euch nur um
diese terroristen den medien kommt eine
besondere verantwortung zu
so viel wie wir über diese verbrecher
berichten die den angriff auf chapter
ausführten sowie nicht sollten wir den
arbeiter aus mali vergessen
größeren kaufhaus arbeitete und einige
geiseln rettete indem er sie im kühlraum
versteckte die französische regierung
verlieh ihm unterdessen die
staatsbürgerschaft oder denken wir auch
an den französischen polizisten der sein
leben für frankreich es wird immer auch
viele christliche und jüdische
verbrecher geben
aber das heißt nicht dass die iren ganze
religion dafür verantwortlich ist
ich finde es betrüblich dass die
westlichen medien dem so wenig
aufmerksamkeit schenken
in der türkei bemühen wir uns immer
beide seiten einer geschichte zu
beleuchten
aber in solchen fällen ist es eine frage
der klugheit
finden sie dass die westlichen medien
oft einäugig sind ja schon ein wenig es
geht ja nicht nur um die straßen europas
ich denke die europäer fürchten sich
jetzt um sind etwas in panik es enthalte
zeiten auch für die muslimischen
gemeinden in europa ich denke es braucht
einen verstärkten dialog
aber vielleicht sollten wir auch mehr
tun um diese leute zu integrieren
ich weiß dass in der schweiz eine
ansehnliche zeit wirken lebt die hier
arbeiten
nicht alle sind so glücklich und
privilegiert wie ich ich hatte glück
besuchte sehr gute schulen meine familie
unterstützt mich ich hatte eine tolle
karriere aber nicht alle haben die
gleichen möglichkeiten im leben die
meisten türken die hier leben sind
arbeiterfamilien ein anderer
ich verstehe sehr gut was sie sagen was
viele von uns denken ist dass die
pressefreiheit immer absolut sinn muss
ja natürlich und charlie hebdo waren
mittel um das zu beweisen
auch wenn jedermann weiß dass die auf zu
weit gehen und kropp sind manche sagen
aber schon das ist so absolut wenn
pressefreiheit bedeutet dass man alles
sagen und schreiben darf lassen sie mich
klarstellen sie ist absolut und alles
was ich als journalistin als muslimin
sagen will ist dass ich meine westlichen
kollegen bitte kein öl ins feuer zu
gießen
das zu sagen hatte ich das recht auch
als ich mit philipp von charlie hebdo
sprach doch wenn sie weiterhin solche
karikaturen veröffentlichen wollen
was sollte ich tun der koran sagt
einfach halte ich fern
denn wenn sie darauf bestehen dass zu
tun kann ich nichts dagegen unternehmen
ich kann diese leute nicht zwingen
solche zeichnungen nicht zu zeigen wenn
ich sie richtig verstehe ich sagen sie
ihr westlichen journalisten habt schon
das recht aber ihr müsst es nicht
dauernd nutzen
es gibt auch gute gründe naja vielleicht
darf ich dazu etwas lassen sie mich noch
meinen satz zu ende sprechen
sagen wir es mal so es gibt einige
sensible sacrow sandte bereiche für
muslime wie auch für juden und ich sage
nur bringt eure botschaft zeichnete
karikaturen aber bei den muslimen ist es
der prophet er ist ihnen heilig wenn ihr
wollt behaltet die richtung bei aber
vermeidet die heutigen heiligen bereiche
aber wenn sie es trotzdem tun übrigens
in unseren sendungen nach den attacken
auf charlie hebdo hatten wir einige
karikaturisten die sagten das würde ich
nicht tun dass die leute von charlie
hebdo sind die die zeigen wollten
die freiheit muss absolut zeigt es gibt
ja bekanntlich eine debatte über das
wesen der medien was ist heute die
aufgabe der medien sollen sie
provozieren oder sollen sie vielmehr
berichten darlegen und reflektieren im
dienste der wahrheitsfindung
wenn so etwas wie wahrheit gibt die
menschen zum nachdenken über mögliche
lösungen bringen
ich finde nicht die aufgabe der medien
ist bloß auf probleme hinzuweisen
sondern den versuch zu unternehmen
lösungsmöglichkeiten aufzuzeigen
in dem die journalistin unvoreingenommen
recherchieren
das wird wohl manchmal ignoriert
zugunsten eines journalismus dessen
priorität es ist aufsehen zu erregen
schlagzeilen zu machen und empörung zu
schüren
auch wenn sich die medien gewandelt
haben doch ich denke nicht dass die
medien sich im grundsatz ändern sollten
die medien sollten für die besserung der
gesellschaft arbeiten nicht für die
verschlechterung das ist der eine punkt
der andere punkt auf den ich hinweisen
will ist dass die menschen der realität
in die augen schauen sollen
ich bin nicht französische
staatsbürgerin aber ich sehe dass
innerhalb europas frankreich
eingeschlossen und auch die schweiz ein
dramatischer demografischer wandel
stattgefunden hat und ich frage mich ob
sich nicht im gefolge dieser
veränderungen gewisse haltungen
handlungsweisen und wechselbeziehungen
anpassen sollten
ich hörte meine französischen kollegen
viel von der säkularen gesellschaft
reden frankreich ist eine säkulare
gesellschaft aber gleichzeitig sind die
dinge im fluss in china haben wir diesen
begriff des man muss anpassungen
vornehmen damit man mit den
veränderungen schritt halten kann
in frankreich ist das ein unantastbares
prinzip der staat ist laizistisch ich
denke man sollte nicht mit dem finger
auf eine andere kultur oder religion
zeigen und ihr einen sticker auf die
stirn kleben wo draufsteht wenn du von
diesem land dieser kultur diese religion
kommst dann bist du dies und dies eine
ganze liste von adjektiven vielmehr
sollte man sich überlegen was man tun
kann damit diese menschen ein ebenso
leichtes leben haben wie
damit wir zusammen zum wohl der
gesellschaft arbeiten können
ich glaube das ist ein denkanstoß nicht
nur in europa auch in der türkei in der
schweiz und frankreich aber auch in
china
wir haben bei uns eine ganze menge
vergleichbarer themen die wanderarbeiter
die aus äußerst armen ländlichen
gegenden in die großstädte kommen so
dass wir statt menschen uns fragen warum
sind die so anders als wir müssen wir
denen wirklich platz einräumen ihren
doch einen völlig anderen lebensstil in
einer gesellschaft sollte die rolle der
medien seien denkanstöße in dieser
richtung zu geben nämlich nach lösungen
ausschau zu halten und nicht stimmungen
aufzuheizen
über die rolle der medien kann man
natürlich diskutieren und es ist
wunderbar dass wir diese debatte
wir haben absolut und als jemand der an
schweizer hochschulen kurse in
journalismus gibt kann ich sagen das ist
viele junge europäische und wohl auch
amerikanische journalistin gibt die
davon träumen in ihrem beruf der angst
die rolle zu spielen
die robert redford und dustin hoffman im
film oder präsenz men spielt nämlich
eine regierung zu fall zu bringen
wie sehen sie das was ist die rolle des
journalismus erziehung und haltung oder
enthüllung
danke für diese frage genau darüber
möchte ich sprechen
ich denke die meinungsäusserungsfreiheit
sollte im journalismus nicht selbstzweck
sein journalismus sollte die wahrheit
ans licht bringen
er sollte der besserung der gesellschaft
dienen er sollte die fakten aufzeigen
es geht darum zur wahrheit vorzudringen
das ist die essenz des journalismus zur
meinungsäusserungsfreiheit möchte ich
folgendes sagen wäre ich der
karikaturist würde ich mir überlegen
wohlverstanden ich respektiere deren
recht zu schreiben was sie wollen
aber wenn sie ihre karikaturen zeichnen
wem hilft das hilft es den gemäßigten
der islamischen welt oder hilft es den
extremisten wem spielt es in die hände
sie müssen also auch an die auswirkungen
ihrer arbeit denken ja sicher die
meinungsäusserungsfreiheit sollte klug
angewendet werden weil es ja um das wohl
der gesellschaft geht
wir leben doch in einer welt die mehr
dialog zwischen den verschiedenen
kulturen und in verschiedenen religionen
braucht wäre ich die leute von charlie
hebdo würde ich durchaus karikaturen
zeichnen die denkanstöße geben aber
denkanstöße die zu mehr gegenseitigem
verständnis führen
sie sollten nicht unbehagen hervorrufen
denn die mehrheit der muslime fühlt sich
wegen der karikaturen sehr unwohl weil
es gegen ihr heiligstes ging und ich
weiß auch dass es in der jüdischen
religion viele strenggläubige gibt sogar
der papst hat diese karikaturen
verurteilt denn als repräsentant des
christentums und angehöriger einer
biblischen religion störte sich
ebenfalls daran
es ist also keine rein muslimische
angelegenheit die franzosen haben eine
tradition der satire auf der religiösen
satire
ich verstehe das sieht man nicht in
vielen anderen ländern
und ich stelle fest dass sie sich dessen
gar nicht bewusst sind ich behaupte
nicht dass sie es absichtlich tun aber
überlegen wir doch wem hilft dass ich
meine es hilft den extremisten weil es
ihnen einen sehr guten vorwand lief das
ist ein sehr plausibel gedanke ich
verstehe das vollkommen und viele
liberale muslime haben probleme damit
umzugehen weil es sie in eine schwierige
lage bringt wie sollen sie nun diese
karikaturen verteidigen
sie haben vollkommen recht sie wollen
doch den terrorismus verurteilen
ich möchte nun muss ich aber die
kooperation wieder übernehmen
wir sind drei moderatoren hier aber ich
bin der boss hier entschuldigen
vor wenigen minuten hat mich wie auf
charmante weise kritisiert die
stereotypen moniert welche dieser
westliche schweizerische neutrale typ da
von sich gab wie steht es denn mit der
pressefreiheit in ihrem china und ihre
türkei ich versuche es mal auf eine
andere art zu sagen
vor jahren habe ich ihre damalige
ministerpräsidentin kann so schiller
interviewt und wir sparen auch darüber
in ihrem land kann man nicht immer alles
sagen sie müssen als journalistin
manchmal vorsichtig sein
ja das ist wahr danke auch für diese
frage interessanterweise hatten wir
damals eine frau als ministerpräsidentin
die türkei ist eines der wenigen
muslimischen länder die modernen genug
sind eine frau zur ministerpräsidentin
zu wählen
genau das hat sie mir geantwortet sie
sagte stefan wer regiert irland jetzt
haben wir allerdings auch mehrere frauen
stefan sie haben recht die türkei hat
auch noch einen weiten weg zu gehen
die presse ist unter druck und die
journalisten haben es schwer
ich will hier ehrlich sein aber ich
glaube an mein land weil ich glaube dass
es besser wird
es ist nicht alles schwarz weiß
einerseits haben wir ein sehr gutes
bildungssystem frauen arbeiten
wir haben eine sehr fortschrittliche
interpretation des islam wir haben
demokratie
einerseits hat die neue akp regierung
den druck auf die medien verstärkt und
einige journalisten haben ihren job
verloren
die letzten jahre waren schwierig auch
ich habe meinen job verloren
ja ich habe ihren twitter-account
verfolgt ich habe das gelesen
sie waren offenbar nicht mit allem
einverstanden ich glaube trotzdem an
mein lang denn die türkei ist anders in
nordkorea oder in ägypten kann man die
medien unterdrücken
doch die türkei hat eine derart lange
demokratische tradition seit den 1920 er
jahren haben wir ein parlament die
türken haben die demokratie so lange
genossen dass es nicht möglich ist die
türkischen medien zu unterdrücken
sie bleiben optimistisch doch wie gingen
sie mit dem druck um
ich bekomme viel unterstützung in der
öffentlichkeit als mein abgang von
meiner abteilung bekannt gegeben wurde
es gab keine begründung ich wurde
einfach entlassen
das wurde die große geschichte auf den
frontseiten die menschen unterstützen
mich das weltwirtschaftsforum lud mich
als medial edel nach davos ein um über
die pressefreiheit zu sprechen
und vorher hatten sie da aufgepasst was
sie sagt nur da dachten sie solange ich
hier arbeite nein ich wollte keine
selbstzensur
doch in der türkei hat das klima in den
letzten jahren geändert doch nochmals
lassen sie mich das betonen
es wird sehr schwer sein das türkische
volk zu unterdrücken
es hat zu lange die demokratie genossen
um das hinzunehmen
darum vertraue ich auf mein land und
unsere wirtschaft dass es sich wieder
zum besseren wendet ray was glauben sie
ist enthüllung von illegalen
machenschaften von behörden welche dinge
tun die sie nicht tun sollten ist dies
auch eine wichtige aufgabe des
journalismus in ihrem land durchaus dank
der beziehungen die ich habe sowohl im
internationalen medienrat des
weltwirtschaftsforums wie auch als
medial
und als young global leader seit
mehreren jahren denke ich eine menge
diskussionen die wir hier haben am wef
gehen der frage nach wie können wir
diese diversifizierte welt noch
verstehen
wie können wir erreichen dass diese welt
offen genug ist und niemanden ausgrenzt
wie können wir erreichen dass wir
menschen nicht einfach nach kriterien
einteilen sie sind ein mann ok 38 in
ordnung folglich werden sie so oder so
sein
das ist eine so altmodische gewohnheit
dass man sie brechen muss die menschen
reisen erfahren andere ansichten sie
haben freunde aus aller welt
höchste zeit um über die eigenen grenzen
hinaus zu schauen
in meinem land zum beispiel ist eine
große anti korruptions bewegung
entstanden da sind hochgestellte
führungspersönlichkeiten von ihren
posten entfernt worden
dabei hat die presse eine rolle gespielt
so viel ich weiß gibt es auch auf
höchster ebene diese anti korruptions
kampagne genau und es ist nicht nur eine
einmalige säuberungsaktion unser
präsident jean ping hat kürzlich einige
verlautbarungen zur nachhaltigkeit
dieser kampagne gemacht
offenbar hat chinas herrschen der
kommunistische partei realisiert wie
wichtig es ist die korruption
auszurotten
damit die partei selbst dauerhaft
bestehen kann
und die politik in china immer sauberer
wird
und ganz wichtig nichtsdestotrotz für
ein lokaljournalist auf mittlere ebene
dürfte es wohl schwierig sein
gegen den bürgermeister einer großen
stadt abzutreten
ich glaube stefan aufgabe eines
reporters ist nicht nur aufzuschreiben
was ihnen ihre
quellen auf dem papier sagen so einfach
ist es nicht es braucht klugheit und ein
ganzes soziales netz mithilfe dessen sie
ihre geschichte zusammenbringen und
veröffentlichen können
ihre geschichte soll auf eine positive
wirkung haben
ich rede nicht von reißerischen
geschichten man muss darum bemüht sein
dass die geschichte die gesellschaft
voranbringen das ist die rolle des
journalisten nicht einfach sich zu sagen
ich habe ja die
meinungsäusserungsfreiheit also schreibe
ich alles was ich gehört habe
journalisten brauchen verstand sie
brauchen verstand unter verschiedenen
umständen und in verschiedenen systemen
es ist ein training unserer klugheit
bedeutet dass auch die richtige methode
zu finden wie man etwas sagt etwa zur
korruption die passenden worte zu finden
und vorsichtig zu sein
ist es das was sie und klugheit
verstehen es wird viel diskutiert in
meinem land über diese anti korruptions
kampagne und wohin sie führen wird
denn viele fragen wurden gestellt auch
in meiner sendung etwa ob diese kampagne
nur eine einmalige sein
das war bevor der präsident seine
anmerkung zur nachhaltigkeit dieser
kampagne gemacht hat es wurde auch
gefragt ob diese individuellen aufgrund
der kampagne von ihren posten und ämtern
entfernt werden oder auch ob wir die
antikorruptions politik
institutionalisieren sollen damit
korruption schon in den anfängen
ausgemerzt werden kann so dass erstens
niemand es wagen würde sich bestechen zu
lassen
zweitens das system nicht den geringsten
spielraum für korruption offen lässt und
drittens die kultur der korruption im
politischen system ausgerottet werden
kann sodass die zukünftige generation
chinesischer beamten und horka dabei
staatseigenen unternehmen keinen
gedanken darauf verschwenden muss ob sie
spielraum für bestechung haben oder
nicht
dies ist der prozess warum wir in china
über neue gesetze sprechen
es ist keine bloße kampagne es geht
darum ein system zu errichten
landes so dass sowohl das symptom als
auch die ursachen bekämpft werden können
ich möchte noch beifügen es ist überall
ähnlich nicht nur mit chinas anti
korruption sondern auch mit der
verständigung zwischen verschiedenen
völkern und kulturen wie können wir nur
an paris denken ohne an die
wirtschaftlichen ursachen zu denken an
die arbeitslosigkeit an die mangelnde
kommunikation zwischen den volksgruppen
und religionen
sie haben sehr richtig betont dass die
verschiedenen kulturen voneinander
lernen können und sollten als sie in
amerika studieren ostküste was sie vom
amerikanischen journalismus war dass ihr
vorbild oder hatten sie vorbehalte als
ich nach amerika kam war ich 18 jahre
alt und besuchte die georgetown school
of service darauf habe ich
politikwissenschaft studiert und im
nebenfach studierte islamwissenschaft
stellen sie sich vor an einer
jesuitenschule in amerika das höhere
bildungswesen in den usa hat viel zu
bieten und verdient eine gute note in
harvard studierte ich internationale
beziehungen und nahost wissenschaften es
war eine offene gesellschaft innerhalb
der usa konnte man die amerikanische
außenpolitik kritisieren und das tue ich
die usa haben im nahen osten im irak und
in afghanistan höchst umstritten der
dinge gemacht das muss ich sagen aber
innerhalb amerikas sind die bürgerlichen
rechte und freiheiten intakt ich hatte
also sechs komfortable studien
verglichen mit europa haben die
amerikaner etwas weniger vorurteile und
die umgebung wo man studiert in harvard
oder georgetown fördert das kritische
denken aber was den journalismus
betrifft da sind wir alle eingebunden in
unsere kulturellen stereotypen rat das
haben die amerikaner
in den amerikanischen medien kann man
über gewisse themen nicht spreche zum
beispiel ein prominenter moderator von
cnn musste abtreten weil er israel
kritisierte jedes land hat seine
tabuthemen und grenzen und das wäre naiv
zu sagen
es herrscht freiheit in amerika und im
rest der welt
wir haben alle unsere eigenen heitling
zonen gibt es für sie beide einen
gemeinsamen nenner darüber was eine gute
story ist ein königreich für eine gute
story eine gute story zu welchem preis
genau das eigentlich ich glaube wir
leben zurzeit in einer sehr delikaten
wert es gibt verrückte menschen in allen
kulturen und religionen und als
medienleute sollten wir besonders
vorsichtig sein
unser erstes ziel sollte die
wahrheitsfindung sein wenn bei charlie
hebdo etwas geschehen ist was war es
wert hat es wer steht dahinter ist es
die el kaida sich an die fakten halten
und nicht zu sehr dramatisieren die
fakten darlegen mit den leuten reden
alles tun aber man soll objektiv sein
das meinte ich als ich sagte
meinungsäusserungsfreiheit sollte nicht
selbstzweck sein
ich finde es interessant dass so nah von
den kulturellen schranken spricht die
journalistin haben können egal woher sie
kommen
das kann tatsächlich sein denn die
herkunft und die unterschiedliche
erziehung sagen sie uns doch noch etwas
über ihren eindruck von der
amerikanischen kultur
lassen sie mich das noch sagen es ist
wichtig zu differenzieren dass wir nicht
einfach stolz sind auf unsere
einschränkungen wir arbeiten daran
ordnung und wir müssen uns ihr stellen
und nicht einfach sagen es gibt nun mal
diese grenzen was kann ich dafür
wir müssen das ändern diese ich kann es
geist im journalismus muss lebendig
bleiben zum wohl der gesellschaft
wir sollten unsere begrenzungen erkennen
unter denen arbeiten zusammen nicht nur
sagen ich bin von hier und du bist von
da ich hasse die sogenannte
andersartigkeit in unseren geschichten
um die anderen kennen zu lernen muss man
zu ihnen gehen
als ich mich auf unser gespräch
vorbereitet er habe ich gelesen dass sie
die lady in der hinteren reihe genannt
wurden als sie als
auslandskorrespondentin anfingen
alle achtung stefan sie haben
recherchiert ja abgesehen von den
stereotypen habe ich mich auch etwas
vorbereitet ich versuchte unauffällig zu
sein weil ich fand ich gehöre nicht in
die erste reihe
erzählen sie uns wie das war es war
interessant denn als ich in washington
als korrespondentin arbeitete war das
eine aufregende zeit für journalisten
wegen des krieges und auch weil man die
turbulenzen der amerikanischen politik
erlebte nach dem elften september
es war kurz danach die journalisten
waren in großer aufregung und gierig
darauf ihre stories herauszubringen der
briefing room im weißen haus war zum
bersten voll
für mich die ich von einem nicht
unbedingt wichtigen und auch nicht
verbündeten land kam
ich war sicher eine kleine kartoffel wie
man sagt wir mussten immer um unsere
plätze kämpfen denn in der vordersten
reihe des briefings postieren sich
normalerweise die führenden
amerikanischen medien gefolgt von
einigen aus alliierten ländern oder
langjährigen korrespondenten und ich als
junge kleine lady aus china musste mit
meinen kollegen darum kämpfen dass ich
mein aufnahmegerät anschließen konnte
aber ich habe mich energisch
durchgesetzt um
fragen zu stellen denn darum ging es mir
damals hier vertrete ich mich selbst
aber damals wollte ich dass die anderen
meine fragen hören die aus einer anderen
kultur einer anderen perspektive kommen
besonders über den krieg sie wissen
vielleicht dass die mehrheit der
chinesen gegen diesen krieg war
inwiefern waren ihre fragen anders
haben sie ein beispiel wenn sie den us
aussenminister fragt hatten sie da
andere fragen als die amerikanischen
mainstream journalisten
manchmal waren die sichtweisen wirklich
ganz unterschiedlich je nachdem woher
wir kamen meistens sah ich dass in
meinen amerikanischen kollegen denen ich
höchsten respekt zollen
es sind namhafte journalisten sie haben
großes geleistet
sie waren gewissermaßen meine mentorin
denn ich habe viel von ihnen gelernt
doch meistens verfolgten sie das
tagesgeschehen während ich als
journalistin aus dem ausland meistens
eher eine gesamtschau pflegte wenn ich
das so salopp sagen darf und hat der
außenminister ihnen geantwortet
der sprecher des state department ja
aber normalerweise sah er mich nicht bis
ich die hand sehr hoch hilft die lady
von der letzten reihe
die lady so kam ich zu meinem übernahmen
der sprecher war äusserst nett genau wie
so nah sagte es ist eine kultur die zum
wettbewerb anregt wenn sie als einzelner
mut klugheit und beharrlichkeit beweisen
werden sie beim namen genannt doch mein
name ist vielleicht schwer auszusprechen
so nannten sie mich die lady von der
letzten reihe und meine westlichen
kollegen amüsierten sich darüber aber
schön daran ist doch auch dass sich
meine kollegen von den us-medien durch
meine frage irgendwie ein bild davon
machen konnten was andere denken
davon sind wir hier gar nicht so weit
entfernt das gleiche geschieht hier und
jetzt in diesem briefing room
bedauerlicherweise läuft uns die zeit
davon
ich könnte endlos mit meinem beiden
kolleginnen hier diskutieren
darum wäre meine letzte frage an sie zu
haben
im sinn diesen beruf ihr ganzes leben
lang auszuüben oder haben sie andere
träume ich werde wohl eine zeit lang
beim journalismus bleiben ich glaube an
diesem beruf und die magie des
journalismus ich möchte jetzt mehr auf
einer internationalen ebene arbeiten wie
ich schon sagte geht es mir nicht allein
um den journalismus
ich fühle dass ich meinem volk schulde
was ich als türken verkörpere als
muslimin als frau es ist diese identität
ich denke wir sind glücksfälle wir haben
das glück hier sein zu können mit ihnen
zu sprechen
der schweizer bevölkerung eine botschaft
zu übermitteln
das ist ein privileg und natürlich auch
eine verantwortung sie nie daran gedacht
in die politik zu gehen um auf direktem
weg die dinge zu verändern
ich habe bei der demokratischen partei
in der türkei für das parlament
kandidiert politik hat sie also gelockt
was hat sie ja aber dann habe ich
begriffen journalisten zu sein ist
besser als politikerin
man ist objektiver und nicht
eingebundenen richtlinien und meine
passion heißt hier darf ich denen die
uns zu schauen noch sagen europa
durchlebt eine heikle zeit und die
schweiz desgleichen wenn sie das nächste
mal ein muslim auf der straße oder and
türken sehen der in der schweiz arbeitet
bitte denken sie an mich und an das was
ich gesagt habe
es ist eine prüfung für uns alle für
muslime den terrorismus zu verurteilen
und uns nicht mit diesen kriminellen in
verbindung bringen zu lassen und für die
europäer die muslime zu akzeptieren ihre
botschaft ist angekommen
wir danken ihnen dafür wir haben noch
eine minute
möchten sie ihr leben lang journalistin
bleiben oder haben sie andere pläne
journalismus ist ein wunderbares
berufsziel doch gleichzeitig möchte ich
vermittlerinnen und internationale
kommunikatorin sein und das nicht nur in
china
ich habe die ambition die welt in mein
land zu holen aber auch der welt mein
land nahe zu bringen
ich möchte noch einmal betonen dass wir
offen sein und uns auf die welt
ausrichten müssen wenn wir das zum ziel
haben dann wird die welt viel viel
besser und syna liebe kolleginnen es war
mir ein großes vergnügen
ich danke
[Musik]